almost famous was such a good movie
you had audition for that I assume yeah
like four times and tons of people
wanted that yeah I remember I'll never
forget that phone call cuz I was
supposed to play a different role I was
supposed to play the sister not Penny
Lane and Cameron didn't want me to
audition well cuz he just saw me as the
sister right and I just said look I'm
and then everybody fell out of the movie
cuz at the time I got the sister it was
Brad Pitt and Sarah Polley really oh my
i was i like stuck in there and I was
turning down other parts and things and
Cameron and I said just please I'm gonna
be in the movie in it but just please
let me audition
why because you sense that it would be
big commercial success no I just love
Cameron Crowe I loved his movies I
watched almost famous with Ryder just
recently right which was really fun
was he in other words he had never seen
you know he's 12 you know it's rated R
movie right so he finally just said mom
come on you know and I was like alright
what do you do you laying in bed eating
popcorn and something I was kind of in
and out of the room you know um and I
would watch him watch it and it was
interesting to see how it held up to
with young like a 12 year old right and
he was like out of his mind
yeah he loved it he loved it hmm yeah
that's good yeah my kids weren't tope in
love with what I was doing so I